recent surveys say asian americans are
reporting
increased harassment and discrimination
during the pandemic
this comes as many work on the front
lines caring for covid 19 patients
for one group the virus is taking an
outsized toll
on people of filipino ancestry they make
up
one percent of the u.s population but
more than seven percent of the nation's
health care workforce
and according to propublica one in four
filipino adults in the new york new
jersey area
works in the medical field elaine
quijano shows us how the community of
caretakers
is coping as my sister-in-law was saying
we could probably
build a hospital or a clinic by
ourselves from nurses to therapists to
doctors
nina bataiola jokes there are so many
health care workers in her family
they could fully staff their own
hospital nina and her husband don ryan
vatayola left the philippines in 2007
to work as occupational therapists in
the u.s
then in early march they found
themselves on the front lines of the
pandemic
and then in late march he started to get
sick i finally called
the emergency um 9-1-1 on him
he couldn't even drink water anymore
days later don ryan was well enough to
facetime from the hospital
we were very hopeful he looked much
better
he didn't like the food so i said like
okay
think what you wanted to eat call me
back and i'll have it delivered
um he never got to call me back
that was it on april 4th don ryan
battalion passed away in new jersey at
age 40.
we thank you for welcoming don to the
gates in heaven
his family paid their respects in an
online service
while you were gone he's one of more
than 50 filipino health care workers who
have died from kovid 19
in the new york new jersey area alone
according to pro-public reporter nina
martin
in 1898 the philippines which had been a
colony of spain became a territory of
the united states
it became one of the places that the us
saw fit to exploit labor from they
basically created a workforce
that has turned the philippines into the
largest
exporter of nurses in the world
many filipino-american health care
professionals work at the bedside or
in critical care the kinds of jobs that
make you most vulnerable in a pandemic
filipino-american nurse jem skorp works
in the icu at elmhurst hospital in
queens new york
once the epicenter of the epicenter have
you been there in some people's final
moments
exactly i have a covet patient the wife
was calling
so of course nobody would touch the
patient so i told the wife i'm not
seeing my wife i'm not seeing my son
so this husband of yours right now
is my family for months he stayed at a
hotel so he could keep working without
infecting his wife and son
family reunions looked like this it must
be so difficult
i can't imagine being separated
it is it's that easy emotionally it is
nursing was gemscorp's path to the
american dream
for nina batayola and her two children
erica and enrico
that dream endures even in this painful
moment
do you see an american dream for them
yes yes i have
a dream for them it might not be the
same american dream that i had before
don ryan loved sneakers bob marley and
of course his family
nina and don ryan had just attained part
of their american dream
they both became u.s citizens last year
and gail as an american of filipino
descent the story reminds me of my aunt
maitita butz she is a nurse in the
chicago area
and for her and so many other health
care workers of all backgrounds it's
really a calling
to risk your own health each day to help
strangers
in need and gail i've heard you say it
time and time again on cbs this morning
we are all so grateful to all of them
we really are i mean these are truly the
front line people
then i was thinking when you think about
the filipino culture
is it is it very common that people want
to go into the medical profession elaine
it is it really is and there's also this
sense of hospitality
which is very much part of the culture
as well one thing that you'll hear
people talk about
is that they always have a smile on
their faces when they walk into a
patient's room
because to them that patient and
especially in this time of covid
with no family able to visit that
patient
becomes their family so this idea of
hospitality of family of caregiving
is really part and parcel of the
filipino culture
was it something you ever thought about
did you ever i'm glad you didn't but did
you ever think about it
i was supposed to there are certain
tracks that you are highly encouraged
to follow i'm the child of filipino
immigrants
and nurses doctors health care workers
engineers those are all those tracks but
i took a different
path but we're so grateful i'm glad
you're right
i know a lot of family members overseas
as well i have relatives who are doctors
and nurses who are battling covid19 each
and every day as well so
it's really truly a cultural kind of
experience
and they very much are on the front
lines
i'm so glad you're with us elaine and
the thing that stuck out to me what you
just said
about going into someone's room and
smiling and just to give a little bit of
human connection because the thing that
scares me so much about this and touches
me
is that someone is there alone and
surrounded by
no one who knows them and cares about
them
just to have somebody that smiles and
looks at you and really cares makes such
a difference
especially during these times elaine
quijano thank you so much
always good to see you